good evening ladies and gentlemen it's
my great pleasure to welcome you to the
41st student academy awards the student
academy awards were created in 1972 as
an extension of the Academy's mission to
engage filmmakers at the college level
support emerging voices and celebrate
the excellent work that is being done by
young filmmakers worldwide that mission
is stronger than ever in addition to
these awards the Academy now presents an
extensive year-round program of grants
educational programs media literacy
outreach special screenings and other
programs all in an effort to cultivate
the next generation of filmmakers who
represent the future of our industry and
our Academy every year more than 500
college and university students from
around the world compete for Student
Academy Awards their films are judged in
five categories animation documentary
narrative alternative and foreign we
present up to three awards in each
category gold silver and bronze which
we'll be revealing on stage tonight I'd
like to thank the 76 Academy members who
served as judges we could not keep up
this wonderful Academy tradition without
their long hours of dedication and I
want to express my heartfelt
congratulations to our student winners
you've joined an elite group of
filmmakers whose ranks include as you
saw Robert Zemeckis John Lasseter Pete
dr. Lauren lazin Trey Parker and Spike
Lee along with many other celebrated
filmmakers who have gone on after
winning student academy awards to earn
more than 46 Oscar nominations
and have won or shared aid Oscars I hope
for each of you your student academy
award is the first step in a very long
and successful career I can speak for
all of us at the academy when I say we
can't wait to see what your futures hold
now I would like to introduce our first
presenter to kick off the night with the
documentary category an actor and
documentary filmmaker himself Adrian
Grenier